[Musique]
bonsoir à tous un preuve par TR spéciale
dans cette entre de tour des élections
régionales jamais en effet ce scrutin
qui doit redessiner la carte de la
France n'aura pris une telle importance
non pas en raison du nombre réduit à
l'avenir de de région mais bien sûr avec
la percée historique dimanche dernier du
Front national il s'agit selon les mots
répétés par Manuel Vals aujourd'hui de
défendre la République nous avons donc
trois invités pour débattre de cette
question ce soir avec nous perine
exactement Michel avec nous sur ce
plateau philippe Dallier sénateur les
républicain de scène saintden bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous Gilbert
Collard député Front national du vaulus
non non non non non non non du gare du
garedon du G Marion maréchal Le Pen qui
est député du VUS moi je suis député de
la deuxème circonscrition du gare 1
excuses et Jean-Pierre suer sénateur
socialiste du Loiré alors nous allons
garder les les trois questions qui
rythment comme chaque semaine cette
émission perine oui trois parties la
première partie avec cette question qui
va s'afficher sur vos écrans le Front
national peut-il être contré dans les
régions où il est arrivé en tête
dimanche soir deuxème question comment
en est-on arrivé là et pu trè question
partie exactement 3è partie de cette
émission spéciale l'émergence de trois
blocs de du tripartisme finalement
annonce-t-elle demain une recomposition
politique première question donc le
Front national peut-il être contré la
question porte bien sûr sur la
mobilisation des abstentionnismes et
puis également sur les reports de voie
notamment une au sein d'e d'une gauche
qui qui était bien fracturé hier et qui
aujourd'hui se rassemble ce Rabi Bosch à
la hâte grande inconnu également bien
sûr la portée du rempart républicain
dans trois régions où le Front National
est arrivé largement en tête philippe
Dallier le Front national peut-il être
contré selon vous benah écoutez je
l'espère rendez-vous dimanche soir à 20h
pour constater effectivement quelle aura
été la réaction des Français après ce
qui a été un premier tour difficile pour
nous euh maintenant moi je pense
effectivement qu'il y aura une
mobilisation pour le second tour et
qu'on verra venir des électeurs qui ne
se sont pas déplacés un surceau
républicain une sorte de surceau
républicain écoutez on verra il est
certain également que des électeurs
s'étant déplacés au premier tour et ne
retrouvant pas les candid pour lesqu ils
avaient voté n'iront peut-être pas voter
maintenant je pense que il y a quand
même un grand risque que le Front
national emporte un certain nombre de
régions et qu'il va falloir un véritable
sursaut en notre faveur notamment pour
effectivement éviter que TR qu régions
tombent dans l'escarcelle du front sur
également donc des électeurs de gauche
dans tris régions Jean-Pierre suer
est-ce que vous seriez prêt dimanche
prochain à votter sans État d'â pour
Christian est Xavier Bertrand ou encore
Philippe Richer absolument parce que je
pense que c'est la dignité du Parti
socialiste que d'avoir fait à cet égard
un choix très clair mais je veux
répondre à votre première question en
vous disant que bien sûr je pense que le
Front national peut-être doit être battu
je parlerai de ma région je la connais
centre valdeloire voyez-vous il reste
trois candidats deux peuvent gagner le
Front National qui a fait 30
%. les socialistes avec François bonau
notre président sortant et tout à
l'heure vous avez dit un mot qui m'a un
peu fait réagir vous avez dit Rabi
Baucher mais
voyez-vous les les représentants de la
gauche dans notre région gèrent ensemble
la région depuis longtemps et ça se
passe bien dans de très bonnes
conditions et par conséquent le
rassemblement autour du président s'est
fait très bien et aujourd'hui mais ce
n'est pas le cas partout notamment au
niveau national Jeanpierre c'est le cas
dans la région Centre valdeoire et
aujourd'hui auourdi aujourd'hui les gens
ont le choix entre le Front national
avec tout ce que ça représente ou
l'union derrière françois bonau Gilbert
Colard écoutez l'infemme que je suis est
très honoré d'être avec vous
et ému que vous le tolériez je voudrais
faire deux observations qui vous
concernent si vous le permettez la
première c'est que c'est un débat entre
vous trois hein non non mais vous avec
moi vous n'y échappez pas parce que je
considère que vous n'êtes pas des
mécaniques et que ce que vous dites vous
engage et que le respect qu'on vous doit
c'est de ne pas aller dire ce qu'on
pense quand vous n'êtes plus là vous
parlez de sursaut républicain vous
parlez de rempart
républicain
mais vous pensez vous pensez vraiment
monsieur que il faut un sursaut parce
qu'on est un danger je je je citais le
Premier ministre qui aujourd'hui
noné répblque qui éit je alors vous
pouvez répondre pouvez répondre au prier
ministre il a dit non non j'ai bien
écouté ce que vous avez dit et je note
moi au fur à mesure j'étais à
l'Assemblée je l'ai entendu du reste ça
m'a fait éclater de rire il a dit il
faut défendre la République moi je
préférerais qu'il nous défend contre
daesh contre le chômage contre la
pauvreté enfin bon chacun ses objectifs
je crois franchement et moi moi ça ne me
touche même plus voyez-vous parce que
j'ai j'ai j'ai pas de preuve à faire bon
mais je pense que c'est insulé
franchement
directement tous les braves gens qui
votent pour nous qui respectent la
République moi je suis député de la
nation et je demande à être respecté à
ce titre même par le Premier ministre la
République je la défends à l'Assemblée
je je je me bat avec les armes de la
démocratie et je trouve vraiment une
seconde j'aurais terminé mais après si
vous voulez je ne parlerai plus hein non
mais je non non mais je je si si on a
plein de question là je veux crever la
bon donc je je vous comprenez défendre
la République alors que en
pasaca monsieurosier était qualifié par
les socialistes de droite extrême et que
à l'intérieur même des socialistes il y
a une bronca d'élus qui disent on aurait
dû se maintenir dans le grand test
est-ce que le candidat qui a déposé sa
liste est un fachot ancien sénateur
ministre de Lionel Jospin dire il faut
arrêter un moment donné on peut débattre
on peut discuter on peut avoir tort on
peut avoir tort vous pouvez avoir raison
et l'inverse c'est le renversement du
pour et du contre mais vouloir nous
faire gober des choses pareilles c'est
pas possible peuton évoquer donc les
valeurs et la défense de la République
messieurs je pense que le que le Front
National est un parti qui est
antirépublicain qui ne partage pas les
valeurs de la République lesqu Monsieur
s'il vous plaît je vais vous dire la PR
nationale vous n'arrêtez pas de
stigmatiser les gens qui ont une autre
couleur de peau une autre
religion
diff
monuretteourn je vous laisse débre tous
les deux je P pas déb avec quelqu'un qui
fait de la discrimination et bien
écoutez je vous dis que ce que dit
constamment le Front national pas vraiz
uneine de l'autre voulez et bien je vous
dis ce que je pense que dites ce que
chacun ent je vais vous dire ce que je
pense je pense que vous êtes frappé et
je le dis avec infiniment de courtoisie
mais c'est un diagnostic d'arriération
mentale P alors là c'est peut-être
moi la prère fois
Danson
taxissz-mo'queriss vous par
mêmes ça c'est un fait personnel je vois
pas
pour on traite d'arération ment et c'est
bien la preuve du comportement qui est
constamment le
vaccepte pas cette arriération
ment je non seulement je vous les donne
pas mais je répète et je m'explique je
parle deértion mentale pourquoi parce
que adversaires nos
adversairespr après laiss la Paro je
vrais expliquer sur je lae parole a
peut-être vous avez des regrets quand
votité V vis se sont insult mais
laissez-moi m'expliquer c'est
totalitaire j'ai dis j'ai lâché un mot
monsieur a fait une éruption volcanique
et je peux pas
m'expliquer éruption volcanique j'ai
parlé clairement de votre programme dis
je dis que c'est pas démocratique
d'insulter les gens je parle
d'arriération arriéré mental et c'est
pas
démocratique vous acceptez ça dans
votremion parle d'arération mentale et
si monsieur qui est un démocrate me
laisse m'expliquer il va peut-être
peut-être vous excusez peut-être
peut-être que vous pouvez vous excuser
jeex pas si vous me laissez m'expliquer
je peux m'expliquer j'ai le droit à 2
minutes à une minute d'explication
pourquoi rération mentale c'est relié à
un mécanisme intellectuel c'est pas
relié à une personne c'est un schéma
intellectuel qui est complètement
formolé dans tout le discours des années
39 40 et qui est débordé
dépassé c'est démodé je ne vous mets pas
vous en cause je mets en cause le
discours que vous tenez qui est frappé
d'arrièration mentale je l'ai dit devant
julienr qui m'a donné
raison RA on a typiquement là le genre
d'échange sur lesquel sur lesquel surf
le Front National et Gilbert Collard le
fait
admirableement
écoutez vous vous posez en victime
du système vous êtes là en essayant
d'expliquer aux Français que ils ont
tout essayé donc finalement il ne reste
que vous et voilà tout votre programme
moi ce que je souhaiterais pour
effectivementer le Front national c'est
qu'on parle de votre programme
économique parce que et je prends je
prends ma part de responsabilité et
toute la classe politique devrait
prendre sa part de responsabilité
pendant trop longtemps on a été
effectivement dans le rejet pur et dur
sans même essayer d'expliquer de
décortiquer ce que propose le Front
national résultat ils ont sorfé
là-dessus et c'est gravissime parce
qu'aujourd'hui on entend sur le terrain
des gens qui disent je vote Front
national on essaie d'engager le dialogue
avec eux on essaie de comprendre
pourquoi mais on ne peut même plus
entrer dans le fond des choses on ne
peut plus entrer dans la question
programmatique on est simplement comme
là dans le rejet de la classe politique
de son système et Gilbert Collard joue
là-dessus admirablement cependant il
faut que les Français comprennent bien
que derrière effectivement cette façade
il y a un programme économique qui
serait une catastrophe pour notre pays
et moi c'est de cela dont je voudrais
que nous débattions parce que c'est bien
beau de vre français du vent la sortie
de l'Europe la sortie de l'euro le
retour à la retraite à 60 ans bah
dites-moi que vous ne défendez pas cela
mais moi j'ai lu votre programme on l'a
même fait chiffrer voyez-vous ici au
groupe des Républicains il y en a pour
124 milliards d'euros monsieur ça
vaudrait le coup et qu'on puisse en
débattre parce que sortez un peu de vos
postures par parce que vous nous accusez
souvent d'être dans la posture mais vous
êtes aussi dans la post vous êtes dans
la posture
monsieur et vous évitez le débat vous
esquivez le débat oui vous esquivez le
débat parce que vous êtes sur de
l'affichage et ce qui est terrible pour
nous et je le dis c'est que nous avons
le plus grand mal effectivement à lutter
contre cette cette posture là alors je
vous propose d'écouter là Marion
maréchal Le Pen vous êtes
d'accord un mot sur la préférence
nationale c'est quand même une idée du
Front populaire hein oui FA écoutez Mar
Mar hier hier Mar
Mar je tiens à dire quelque chose si
vous le permettez je tiens à préciser
solennellement que j'ai pensé à quitter
cette émission si je ne la quitte pas
c'est par respect pour vous Madame
tarnaau et Monsieur grossior et pour
philippe Dallier pour tpectateur pour
les téléspectateurs parce que je
considère monsieur card que l'injure et
vouszi compr l'injure l'injure vous
n'avez rien compris pas un argument
politique respectable et le fait qu'au
bout
de minutes d'M vous pratiquiez l'injure
c'est une manière de faire de la
politiqueors éceécoutez pas jugé et vous
n'avez rien compris je me suis expliqué
clairement même ajouté que Juli m'avait
donné raison écoutez maintenant ce que
disait hier Marion Mar le qui expliquait
qu'une pageque tournait en l'écoute et
elle réagissait notamment à à ce rempart
Gilbert Collard que certains donc
tentent de dresser dans trois régions de
France
aujourd'hui le ridicule est à la mesure
de la panique qui est la l'heure car
nous assistons définitivement j'en suis
convaincu à la fin du vieux monde de
leur vieux monde politicien la première
des valeurs de la République bien
c'était la démocratie la démocratie dont
il ne parle jamais d'ailleurs ça ne les
intéresse pas pour la simple et bonne
raison qu'aujourd'hui il la foule au
pied tout simplement ils sont contraints
au vu du retard d'additionner leur
faiblesse pour contrer la force de nos
résultats et bien je le dis il est
scandaleux scandaleux aujourd'hui de
priver les électeurs de la juste
représentation qu' aurait dû alors
Jean-Pierre suer le retrait des listes
socialistes c'est un dén démocratie mais
pas du tout nous considérons que ce
parti est contraire aux valeurs de la
République nous croyons aux valeurs de
la République et par conséquent nous
préférons qu'un républicain même si
c'est un républicain dont je ne partage
pas les idées même si c'est un
républicain que vous combattez tous les
jour c'est un républicain d'abord je ne
combat pas mes collègues qui sont dans
d'autres groupes au Sénat je discute
avec eux je m'oppose mais ce ne sont pas
des ennemis ce sont des adversaires
soyons très clair des adversaires
politiques mais nous avons en commun la
République et c'est pourquoi le parti
quand Mar dit c'est la fin d'un système
vous avez entendu non mais je je ne
crois pas ce n'est pas la fin d'un
système ce n'est pas la fin de la
République la République elle a connu
bien d'autres épreuves et nous avons
fait un choix difficile très difficile
vous savez moi je suis né dans le P
decalis je connais beaucoup de monde
dans le Nord ptecalis c'est un choix
difficile et douloureux mais parce
qu'au-dessus de tout nous mettons le
respect de la République est-ce que vous
comprenez le le refus de votre ami
Jean-Pierre Masseret de refuser de
retirer sa liste dans le grand test
beaucoup beaucoup de respect pour
Jean-Pierre Masseret qui est un homme
très digne mais je je je ne je ne
partage pas sa position qui manque de
dignité hein cette position je dis non
mais manuel Val s'exprime moi je
m'exprime vous m'interrogez je dis que
Jean-Pierre Masseret est un homme
respectable qui qui a qui s'est battu
toute sa vie pour ses idées il fait là
un choix que pour ma part je désapprouve
parce que je suis cohérent avec la
décision de mon parti qui est de tout
faire pour que nos régions soient dirigé
par un républicain y compris un
républicain qui ne partage pas nos idées
politiquesi je Philippe daller Philippe
daller la fin d'un vieux système
politique disait tout à l'heure Marion
éoutz en rêve manifestement tous au
Front national il le rêve que d'une
chose c'est de renverser la table hein
du passé faisons table rase et puis on
verra bien ce qu'il en sortira ceci
étant dit sur le le moi je pense que le
retrait des listes socialistes est une
erreur en matière de stratégie politique
je pense que c'est une erreur parce que
rendez-vous dimanche soir nous verrons
qui aura eu raison qui aura eu tort je
pense que les électeurs d'abord ça amène
de l'eau au moulin du Front national
quand ils disent c'est l'UMPS c'est le
système ils sont tous pareils et ils
sortfent là-dessus également et donc
c'est apporter de l'eau à leur moulin et
par ailleurs je ne suis pas du tout
certain que dans l'électorat dans ces
différentes régions on est le résultat
que vous escomptez donc moi j'aurais
préféré alors effectivement il y a le
risque que le Front national s'empare de
région mais ceci étant dit moi je pense
aussi à la suite à l'élection
présidentiellez préféré alors j'aurais
préféré que les listes socialistes se
maintiennent et que les électeurs
fassent le choix qu'ils ont à faire
voilà je ne veux pas donner l'idée que
qui plaant au Front national qu'il y
aurait d'un côté le Parti socialiste de
l'autre côté les républicains que tout
ça c'est exactement la même ch républain
2002 ne marche plus aujourd'hui
finalement d'abord 2002 c'était une
élection présid pridenti on ne parle pas
de la même chose on ne parle pas de la
même chose là on est sur des élections
régionales vous me permettrez de
relativiser nous sommes en plus dans un
contexte très particulier l'élection
présidentielle en 2017 je le redis ça
sera complètement différent mais là je
pense que le Parti socialiste fait une
erreur de stratégie politique Gilbert cl
oui moi je je suis concerné de voir à
quel point le Parti socialiste bfoue les
lois de la République et de la
démocratie quand on c'est son on a le
droit de se
retirer je peux finir ma phrase maisou
tout à fait vous êtes très aimable bien
sûr qu'on a droit de se retirer on a
même le droit de se
coucher je pense que quand on est élu on
l' parce qu'on peut gagner mais aussi
parce qu'on peut perdre et l'électeur
qui vous donne sa voix il vous la donne
à sachant que vous pouvez gagner comme
etttre dans l'opposition c'est ce que
nous avons toujours fait
démocratiquement c'est ce que je fais
démocratiquement à l'Assemblée en
utilisant les armes juridiques de la vie
parlementaire qu'un grand parti comme le
Parti socialiste certes aujourd'hui
effondré
renonce renonce renonce complètement à
participer à la vie démocratique en
siégeant dans l'opposition je trouve que
c'est comme le dit Monsieur menui faire
CCU deux fois les électeurs monsieur
Menucci faire cocu deux fois les
électeurs bon je pense qu'il y a là un
véritable dénis de la vie démocratique
un véritable mépris de la vie
républicaine qui à mon avis va peser sur
l'histoire du Parti socialiste parce que
les électeurs seront toujours en droit
de dire mais pourquoi n'avez-vous pas eu
le courage d'aller vous opposé dans les
hémicycles par les par les armes
démocratiques au Front national vous
avez déserté pour apporter vos voix à
des à des hommes que vous que
que affronter plutôt qu'esquiver vous
donnez RA oui mais voilà écoutez j'ai
pas ces idées on est opposé sur tout
mais voilà un homme que je respecte
parce que il est il est dans le respect
des lois républicaines il est pas dans
la tambouille politique affronter plutôt
attendeur je crois que nous sommes très
nombreux à montrer ici et dans d'autres
lieux que nous ne craignonss pas le
débat et d'ailleurs monsieur Colard je
ne laisserai rien passer ah j'espère
bien tout à l'heure plus tout à l'heure
vous avez ajouté une nouvelle imposture
oui bien sûr oui voyez-vous vous avez
dit quand j'ai parlé de la préférence
nationale d'ailleurs le front
populaireoui gouver
ioui oui oui alors le Front populaire
revendiqué par le Front national pour
défendre ses idées xénophobe oui parce
que xénopobe et bien moi non mais moi je
tiens ne dites pas n'importe vou moi ne
dites pas cela je n'ai pas dit cela j'ai
dit que le Front national fait dire au
Front populaire ce qu'il n'a jamais dit
et utilise vous comprenez moi je suis
monsieur col su je
suis un élu du département de Jan et de
beaucoup d'aut et bien je
n'accepte je n'accepte
pas pas que vous
utilisiez populaire et cela montre que
vous détournez l'histoire de
France ce que je dis mieux je me porter
je vous très calmement que vous êtes
tour
oui mais très heureux vis-à-vis de vous
vous dans le parti est une imposture
vivante il le prouve aujourd'hui avec
ses accords contre nature alors que
répondezvousieur PHPP par exemple à
notre invité qui saficeous
Fa à fait écoutez je mais tout à fait je
la depuis le début de l'émission c'est
le grand show de Monsieur Colard on a
l'habitude c'est
systématiquement systémati c'est
systématiquement la même chose bon
écoutez écoutez vous me permettrez d'en
placer une quand même parce que je dis
depuis le début de cette émission
monsieur je suis tout seul là vous êtes
deux contre moi peut-être même je dis
monsieur et et vous allez le supporter
que depuis le début de cette émission
vous êtes dans votre grand show
classique vous voulez on n'arrive pas à
entrer dans le détail des choses parce
que à partir du moment où on entrerait
dans le détail des chosesta sur la
préférence
nationale vousz laiss agresser sans rien
dire excusez-moi mais par rapport au
propos que vous avez tenu mais qu'est-ce
que j'ai dit je soutiens que le Parti
socialiste est atteint d'arriération
mentale il a
pas préc tout à l'heure vous n'écout pas
vous écoute oui bien sur la préférence
nationale Philippe dier sur la
préférence nationale répondez sur laér
préférence nationale puisqu'elle est
effectivement revendiquée et assumé par
exemple je POS
je rép PhIP répondrai après phppe la
préférence nationale est l'un des crédau
du Front national il y a des textes il y
a des lois dans ce pays alors soit
monsieur Collard nous propose de changer
les lois changer la constitution changer
les traités européens et puis il nous
expliqua après comment au Parlement à
l'Assemblée nationale ici au Sénat on
inscrit sa préférence nationale dans les
Tex ouais il y a des candidats les
républicains qui proposent qui proposent
aussi pour cette élection régionale une
préférence
régionale réionale non mais là aussi
qu'est-ce qu'on met derrière ces term là
s'il s'agit de savoir si effectivement
dans les régions dans les communes on
peut dans les achats faire des circuits
courts en privilégiant les entreprises
locales c'est de ça dont on parle
excusez-moi ça existe quasiment partout
mais c'est mais de reprendre ce terme
c'est de courir un peu après auss Front
national
non je pense l'UR invoqué par exemple
pas il l'a dit mais en tous les cas
programme sachons ce que l'on met
derrière les les mots dans ce pays il y
a des citoyens français quel que soit
leur couleur leurs origines leurs
conviction religieus qu'il en a ou qu'il
n'en a pas et il y a des étrangers qui
sont en situation régulière et qui on
ont des droits je ne parle pas de ceux
qui sont en situation irrégulière ça
c'est une constatation un état de fait
et aujourd'hui la loi traite les uns ou
les autres de manières différentes en
fonction des sujets mais il y a des
sujets sur lesquels il n'y a pas de
distinction monsieurard devrait nous
préciser
l c'était mon tour très calmement ser
mais attendez
vous vous êtes quand même extrêmement
bizarre il serait tempant en effet merci
Docteur alors Jean-Pierre chur allez-y
ce qui n'est pas acceptable c'est la
discrimination ethnique pour
l'attribution de logement d'emploi qui
figure nomément dans le programme du
Front national d'autre part il y a
quelque chose de sacré voyez-vous dans
la République qui s'appelle le droit
d'asile je suis pour les personnes qui
sont martyrisées oui on est tous
d'accord
et bien nous devons les accueillir dit
le contire et j'entends j'entends des
paroles selon lesquelles il faut
repousser il faut fermer ben regardez ce
qui est dit dans le nord de la France
qui a dit ça il faut fermer il faut
mettre les gens dehors et alors ce qui
dans votre dialectique est étonnant
c'est que quand on vous dit ce que vous
dites vous dites comme ça mais qui a dit
ça personne mais non vous vous rendez
compte tout d'un coup que non vous ne
dites pas ça ben écoutez si vous ne
dites pas ça c'est très bizarre je ne
dis pas moi je n'emploierai pas des mots
comme vous avez employé je dirais que
vous utilisez des arguments qui sont de
bas étage oui bien sûr comme ça vous
retrouver oui oui de bas étage et qui
sont évidemment contraires aux valeurs
de la République et j'ajoute tellement
de choses tellement de choses par
rapport au respect du aux religions
quelle qu'elle soit alors je vous
propose de poser un mot parce qu'on
par rapport à la laité vous on va en
parler on va en parler de la laïité un
mot pass j'ai compris j'ai compris vous
inquiétez pas je je ne vais plus réagir
j'ai à faire un catalogue d'idées reçu
je vais le prendre avec le sourire
mag estce que je veux dire pour pour
pour moi tous les citoyens d'où qu'ils
viennent quelle que soit la couleur de
leur pot s'ils respectent la loi de la
République sont les bienvenus maintenant
j'ai faiblesse oui je
l'admets de préférer de préférer les
préféz aider un Français que quelqu'un
qui a un pays où il peut aller parce que
le français il n'a qu'un seul pays c'est
la
franceou et ça vous l'oubliez voilà
voilà qui est dit alors on aborde la
deuxème question de l'émission vous êtes
tous d'accord sur ce point j'espère
maintenant comment comment le Front
national a-t-il réussi à seer à ce
niveau
électoral responsabilité de la gauche
qui est au pouvoir ou de la droite qui a
été écouté à ce sujet manuel Vals et
Nicolas
Sarkozi chaque fois que la gauche a été
au pouvoir ça s'est traduit par une
explosion du vote d'extrême droite
ensuite trois exemples 1986 monsieur
mitteran fait la proportionnelle 35
députés du Front national de Jean-Marie
Le Pen à l'époque qui rentre à
l'Assemblée nationale 2002 souvenez-vous
5 années de
qu'est-ce qui se passe Jean-Marie Le Pen
au 2e tour la gauche n'est même pas au
2è tour et là 4 années de François
Hollande et c'est une exaspération qui
montre dans le pays Madame Le Pen était
face à moi au premier tour des
présidentielles de 2012 à 18 % ce qui
était déjà beaucoup en 4 ans elle passe
à plus de 27 % comme vous l'avez dit
mais j'entends moi bien sûr et depuis
longtemps la colère les angoisses des
Français sur les questions de de
sécurité sur le chômage sur l'exclusion
sur les peurs mais je ne suis pas venu
ici ce soir sur votre plateau pour
m'excuser je souhaite rappeler quels
sont les enjeux de cette élection
régionale il y a deux conceptions de la
République il y a deux conception de la
France celle de la République qui est
exigeante qui affirme l'autorité qui
veut protéger les Français mais qui veut
aussi les rassembler au nom de nos
valeurs et puis a une vision qui est
celle de l'extrême droite étriqué petite
et qui n'offre aucune solution à ceux
qui souffrent et qui sont
désespérés philippe Dallier on reprends
avec vous parceque vous êtes un petit
peu en retard en temps de de parole je
reprends la question de cette deuxième
partie comment en est-on arrivé là si on
écoute bien le Premier ministre
l'économie et le social ne suffisent pas
à tout expliquer ne suffisent pas
probablement pas mais c'est une bonne
partie de de l'explication l'échec de de
ce gouvernement ou des deux
gouvernements successifs et un taux de
chômage qui atteint des records euh
c'est une grande partie d'exploitation
de l'explication le Parti socialiste a
perdu mais je pense qu'ils doivent
s'interroger sur les raisons mais le
Parti socialiste a perdu l'électorat
populaire ça avait même été théorisé par
Terranova qui à un moment disait bon bah
écoutez les couches populaire c'est
perdu pour le PS tournons-nous plutôt
vers les Français d'origine étrangère
enfin tout cela maintenant il va falloir
que vous demandiez des comptte à ceux
qui vous ont soufflé ces ID c'est un
électorat que vous avez aussi perdu un
électorat que Nicolas SAR Ava l'éectorat
populaire qui qui qui subit la crise de
plein fouet comment voulez-vous
aujourd'hui qu'il ne désespère pas ça
c'est la vraie question qui nous est
posée et tant que dans ce pays nous
n'arriverons pas à faire les réformes
qui permettront de relancer la machine
économique et de redonner du boulot à
une majorité de gens nous n' sortiront
pas et le Front national se refera
là-dessus et puis et puis vous
rajouterez parce que dans ces élections
régionales il y a les attentats du 13
novembre qui manifestement ont joué un
rôle avec une radicalisation d'une
partie de l'électorat qui a trouvé
l'opportunité avec ses élections
d'exprimer aussi sa peur Jean-Pierre sir
est-ce que vous reconnaissez que la
politique suivie qui est définie par le
Premier ministre comme social réformiste
mais qui n'obtient pas pour l'instant de
résultat économique a pu jeter a jeté
effectivement une bonne partie de
l'opinion politique la politique qui est
menée difficile et courageuse et je la
défends bien et nous la menons pourquoi
et je le dis à philippe Dallier parce
que quand Nicolas Sarkozi était
président de la République avec le
gouvernement Fillon
il n'a pas fait baisser le chômage il
n'a pas réduit les déficits il a
augmenté les impôts et cetera et cetera
il n'a pas réduit les charges des
entreprises il n'a pas réduit les
dépenses publiques donc il y a toute une
série de choses crur il a encaissé la
crise mais il y a toute une série de
choses qu'il n'a pas faites et nous nous
avons dû prendre des décisions très
difficile et courageuse et pourquoi je
salue ce que fait François Holland
manuel Vals pour aller dans le sens de
la baisse des charges de la
compétitivité des entreprises et cetera
non mais vous savez tout à fait raison
cela n'est pas suffisamment compris n'a
sans doute pas été suffisamment
expliqué mais je dis les résultats ne
sont pas toujours au rendez-vous mais je
dis que cette politique économique est
celle qui est aujourd'hui nécessaire
j'ajoute quelque chose c'est que en
effet dans le vote de dimanche dernier
il y a eu un contestablement deux et
deux phénomènes premièrement
l'immigration et le fantasme la peur de
voir tous les gens qui arrivent et tous
ces gens qui arrivent qu'est-ce que vous
voulez il fuit la mort hein c'est un
fait et puis deuxièmement bien entendu
ces attentats et alors ces attentats
c'est terrible et moi je tiens à dire
par rapport à cela voyez-vous ce que
fait aujourd'hui François Hollande moi
je veux lui rendre hommage parce que
tant sur le plan intérieur que sur le
plan extérieur il a pris toutes les
décisions qui devaient être prendre
prises il a pris toutes les décisions
pour que la France se défende pour
qu'elle lutte contre le terrorisme alors
c'est la réalité et moi aucune
propagande ne m'empêchera de dire
chapeau à François Hollande et
soutenons-le dans ce qu'il fait contre
daesh et contre le terrorisme en
France voilà François Hollande a au
moins un coup de chapeau ça c'est
bien je revendique vous avez le droit
bon moi je voudrais faire plusieurs
observations si vous le permettez
rapidement j'ai pas de de de raison
funèbre de qui que ce soit à faire en
ventant les louanges de qui que ce soit
je voudrais entrer dans ce qui me paraît
essentiel pour expliquer notre
progression bon Nicolas Sarkozi vous
venez de le dire
remarquablement son quinquena était un
échec merci de l'avoir dit ça m''est
fait gagner du temps pour ce qui est du
Parti socialiste j'ai écouté François
Hollande avec respect parce que je
respecte la fonction présidentielle
quand elle est en exercice euh évoquer
les mesures qu'il allait prendre les
citoyens ont dû faire comme moi il a
d'abord il a d'abord dit que il allait
euh mettre de l'ordre aux frontières et
qu'on allait exercer des contrôles c'est
ce qu'on dit depuis des mois et des mois
et des mois en se faisant traité de
xénophobe de racistes qu'on éétait pas
des républicains et puis il a dit qu'on
allait virer les imames radicaux des
mosquées c'est ce qu'on a c'est ce qu'on
a dit c'est ce qu'on a dit il n pas dit
ça exactement dé entendu ni appliqué
vous déformez après il a dit que on on a
vu que monsieur Vals lui-même l'a dit
qu'on ne pouvait pas recevoir tous les
migrants bon c'est ce que nous disions
depuis très longtemps à l'Assemblée
nationale j'ai pris la parole devant
Monsieur casenuf pour lui demander s'il
était certain que parmi les migrants il
n'y aurait pas des terroristes dans le
drame du
Bataclan l'enquête de police
antiterroristes révèlent que deux ou
trois au moins des terroristes étaient
passés par la filière des migrants bon
alors on deux points la Syrie on disait
il faut se rapprocher c'est inévitable
parce que pour aller au sol on a besoin
de leur troupe de Bachar etassad on nous
disait on n pas question au nom des
valeurs républicaines au nom de votre
morale que je respecte parce que vous
êtes un homme moral c'est bien je ne
peux que le respecter aujourd'hui on se
on se tourne vers Bachar etassad Poutine
même chose
bon ils se sont trompés tout le temps
alors qu'estce que vous répondez à cela
Jean-Pierre et puis philippe Dallier qui
un peu de retard sur certains
revirements récents de la politique
éz moi je n'ai je n'ai pu comme beaucoup
que constater effectivement que François
Hollande et Laurent fabus qui dirigent
la diplomatie française a changé de
position dans notre camp il y a très
longtemps que François Fillon plaidait
effectivement pour une autre
approche vrai ce qui est tout à fait
vrai le gouvernement s'y rend très bien
maintenant mais il nétait pas suivi par
les a maintenant monsieur Collard
n'essayez pas de faire croire au
français non plus que vous avez une
baguette magique et vous seriez capable
d'arrêter ou de prévenir tous les attent
mais est-ce que j'ai dit ça mais écoutez
en tous les cas je vous le dis tous les
cas moi je vous le dis donc
effectivement le Parti socialiste a
changé sa position de ce point de vue-là
mais encore une fois je reviens aussi à
la crise économique parce que le Terrero
premier je pense que c'est la crise
économique l'incapacité de ce
gouvernement a inverser la courbe du
chômage François Hollande a tellement
promis au moment de l'élection
présidentielle de 2012 et quand on
promet on suscite de l'espoir et quand
après quasiment 4 années on se montre
incapable de tenir les engagements qu'on
avait pris comment voulez-vous ne pas
désespérer Bill en cour comment
voulez-vous que les classes les plus
populaires qui votent traditionnement
pour vous ne se soit pas tourné vers
d'autres alors il il ne se tourne pas
non plus vers nous dire qu' ne trouve
pas ses réponses dans les partis
traditionnel c'est pas une question de
parti traditionnelle c'est une question
de de programme économique et politique
c'est la question est de savoir comment
est-ce qu'on réforme ce pays François
Hollande le 31 décembre 2013 il a changé
le social libéralisme on nous a inventé
ça il a changé politique mais il est
incapable d'aller au bout des choses
pour la bonne et simple raison qu'il y a
pas de majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
il sait ce qu'il faudrait faire mais il
ne peut pas le faire et toute la
question c'est la effectivement comment
réformer ce pays comment redonner de
l'air à nos entreprises comment redonner
du pouvoir d'achat aux Français et
là-dessus les solutions du Front
national alors là j'aimerais qu'on en
débatte parce
que c'est du mélanch vousqu pas le débat
aaaimais savoir je ne l'ai jamais vu J
ré parce que il y a deux débats en même
temps alors sur le débat
économique c'est vrai que François
Hollande a marqué une inflexion après
quelques mois après le rapport Gallois
et cetera un an et demi non mais bon et
cette orientation moi je suis vous savez
un rocardien et je le suis depuis
longtemps il fut un temps
même é rardien oui tout à fait et je
pense que Rocard avait tout à fait
raison quand il disait pit pas supporter
tout la
misèreend sur
l'économie des décision jead bien s qu'
fa condition que la part
pr non mais simplement continu à parler
oui vous AZ cité mais oui mais alors
c'est pas pas une bonne
référence alors ça fait donc virage
économique de franolland pas toujours
assumé de la part du gouvernement je
suis très très clair premièrement
puisqu'on a parlé de regard il a dit que
on ne pouvait pas assumer toute la
misère du monde il y a bien longtemps
mais que la France devait prendre toute
sa part ce que le Front national oublie
ah bon deuxièmement deuxièmement sur le
débat économique on a pris des décisions
difficiles il fallait les prendre ell
n'avait pas été pris avant je ne
développe pas sur le terrorisme alors
j'entends ce qui est dit il est tout à
fait clair que suite à des attentats où
on a 140 de nos compatriotes qui sont
morts les autres blessés le président de
la République a a réagi de manière très
ferme l'état d'urgence et cetera on l'a
voté et je moi je crois qu'il a fait ce
qu'il fallait faire à ce
moment-làunre côté monsieur collardcune
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai regardez
tout ce qui a été fait par Manuel Vals
et par Bernard casen extraordinaire et
d'autre part j'ajoute j'ajoute vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure des imames voyez
c'est le genre de simplification qui
fonctionne c'est très intéressant votre
discours faut virer les
imams mais att rad attendez nous avons
fait un rapport au Sénat j'en étais le
rapporteur vous vous rappelez je suis
très clair et précis il faut virer les
in les imames
voyez
radicaux ce qui est très important c'est
d'appliquer la loi de la
République la loi mais attendez la loi
de la République elle dit que lorsquunim
moin noné ou quiconque ou quiconque est
bien d'accord produit des des des
exhortations qui sont l'apologie du
terrorisme qui sont le racisme et cetera
et cetera et bien la loi s'applique
c'est une loi pénale et toutes les
conséquences doivent en être
tiré de parler seul pouroi l' deun en
place mais attendez il y a des
qualifications juridiques pénal où il y
en a il y en a pas
sin avant sinon on n'est pas dans un
état de droit Jean-Pierre suur philippe
Dallier décréter l'état d'urgence pour
un président de la République quel qu'il
soit ça n'est pas une décision facile
bien évidemment qu'au soir du 13
novembre il fallait le faire et le
président de la République l'a fait
est-ce que si après les attentats de
Charlie il l'avait proposé moi je l'ai
demandé moi bien monsieur Colard mais
vous vous êtes omniscient vous non pas
du tout j'ai un peu de bon sens
effectivement si le président de la
République ait fait après les attentats
de Charlie est-ce que la population
française l'aurait accepté aussi
facilement que cela je ne sais pas et
moi je ne jette pas et moi je ne jette
pas la la natè maintenant qu'il faille
avec la plus grande fermeté utiliser
tous les moyens de la loi effectivement
pour renvoyer chez eux ceux qui sont ici
et qui prêchent un discours de haine il
faut le faire il aurait certainement
fallu le faire avant parce que il faut
bien se rendre compte de de de
l'impression que ça laisse sur nos
compatriotes quand on VO l'imam de Brest
qui explique à des gamins que s'ils
écoutent de la musique ils seront
transformés en cochon ou en singe il y a
des discours
qui il y a des discours qui ne sont pas
acceptables et là-dessus on aurait pu
effectivement aller plus vite et plus
fort allez trème question de ce preuve
par 3 maintenant la consécration du
Front national comme troisème force
politique donc à la hauteur des deux
autres annonce demain est un mot un peu
lourd hein plus en plus religieux
attention non est-ce qu'en tous les cas
ce nouveau paysage annonce pour demain
une éventuelle recomposition politique
on va écouter Jean-Pierre rafarin qui
voit la République lui en pleine dérive
qui suppose selon l'ancien Premier
ministre de changer de logiciel
politique on l'écoutant nous voyons bien
que la République est en train de
devenir
impuissante impuissante au tribunal
impuissante à l'école impuissante dans
l'administration impuissante pour
l'emploi que la démocratie n'a pas
d'autorité donc je crois qu'il faut qu'à
un moment ou un autre on accepte de se
dire qu'on peut pas invoquer nous les
républicains tous les jours la Rép la
République si elle n'est pas capable
d'agir donc je crois qu'il faudrait un
jour se mettre autour d'une table des
républicains convaincus de dire comment
on donne du muscle à la République
comment on donne de l'ambition à la
démocratie comment on donne de
l'autorité à notre système politique et
donc je crois qu'il faut des réformes je
crois qu'il faut aujourd'hui apporter
des réponses aux citoyens mais courir
derrière les électeurs qu'il soit du
Front national ou du Front de gauche ça
ne servira à rien
alors philippe Dallier quand vous
entendez ces propos est-ce que vous vous
dites que effectivement demain il
pourrait y avoir je sais pas une
recomposition politique une coalition
des républicains de droite de GA je
pense que c'est à la fois le rêve de
Marine Le Pen et peut-être et c'est
peut-être plus embêtant le rêve du
président de la République actuelle mais
c'est vre parce ah non c'est
certainement pas mon rêve à moi et pour
revenir à ce que je disais au début de
l'émission voilà pourquoi je pense que
la stratégie du retrait des listes du PS
est certainement une mauvaise chose
voilà il ne pense qu'à une chose faire
croire aux Français que tous les autres
sont les mêmes et qu'ils développent les
mêmes politiques ce qui est ennuyeux
aujourd'hui c'est que l'échec du
gouvernement actuel est tel que ça
accrédite cette thèse et donc la
recomposition politique derrière on voit
bien que certains après j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour Jean-Pierre rafarin mais là
je ne partage pas son analyse oui le
front il a raison quand il dit que la
République est en drive en tous les cas
que ce pays et je vais dire ce pays et
pas seulement les politiques pas
seulement ceux qui gouvernent il y a
aussi les Français en face il faut aussi
que les Français comprennent qu'il va
falloir réformer ce pays et que réformer
le pays pour le relancer ça sera
difficile et douloureux et qu'il va
falloir accepter un certain nombre
d'efforts ils ont peut-être trop souvent
vous savez moi j'avais l'habitude de
dire et je vois que Jean-Christophe
rantin a repris la à la même formule en
disant les Français aussi la classe
politique qu'il mérite a toujours voté
pour ceux qui crie le plus fort ou pour
ceux qui promettent la lune alors même
que l'on sait que la Lune est difficile
à décrocher ça conduit parfis des
situations quand vous dites que les
réformes seront difficiles et
douloureuses vous voulez dire pour pour
qui et comment mais pour qui il va
falloir que ça soit pour tout le monde
et qu'on répartisse effectivement la
charge mais il va falloir il va falloir
réduire le poids de la dépense publique
dans ce pays pour réduire les impôts
réduire le poids de la dépenses
publiques ça va être faire des économies
dans les services publics et ça va être
extrêmement compliqué mais si on ne le
dit pas aux Français au moment des
campagnes électorales comment
voulez-vous le leur faire accepter après
on a parfois fait cette erreur dans le
passé le Parti socialiste ils ont été
dramatiques de ce point de vue là en
2012 donc moi je voudrais que l'on parle
de ces sujets là parce que tout le reste
vous savez c'est très facile de
promettre la lune pour demain
aujourd'hui c'est ce que fait le frontc
National les Français nous ont vu à
l'œuvre ils ont tendance à dire ben
écoutez vous avez échoué on va essayer
autre chose il faut penser aussi à la
suite berc est-ce que le Front national
du coup est capable de tenir ce langage
de vérité comme lecre de la lune pour
revenir vers
vous je pense d'abord qu'on est la
première force politique du pays ensuite
tout à l'heure quelque chose a été dit
qui
qui est significatif du comportement
politique vous avez dit à propos de
l'état d'urgence quand j'aiévoqué
Koulibali Charlie vous avez dit je l'ai
noté la population ne l'aurait pas
accepté pas forcément j'ai dit et bien
je vais vous dire une chose le devoir
d'un homme d'État et tout est là et la
différence entre nous elle est là je CIS
écez
c'est je peux pas je vous supportez pas
que je parle mais écoutez vous nous vous
nous interrompez sans cesse vous
souffrez également qu'on réagisse à vos
proposy allez-y je vous en prie allez-y
allez-y al non je vous écoute mais vous
vouliez réagir non je l'ai fait ah bon
d'accord tant mieux vous alliez nous
dire que les hommes d'État é de ce côtél
de l'utre côtééagir voz c'est pour ça
j'ai réagi ça y est c'est fini il y a
pas encore une petite réaction bon alors
tout à l'heure j'ai bien noté la
population l'aurait l'aurait pas accepté
mais un homme d'État qui se rend compte
que la menace est réelle et elle était
réelle puisqueque on a vu le drame du
Bataclan elle était réelle même s'il
sait que ça ne va pas plaire il prend la
décision la différence entre vous et
nous
si je me souviens bien vous êtes
délinant vous non mais vous vous êtes
avocat non mais c'est la vous l'avez dit
ou pas vous l'avez dit franchement vous
l'avez dit ou pas mais attendez
qu'est-ce que vous me Racon tout à
l'heure quand je dis aujour je dis oui
monsieur ça vous embête bien sûr bien
non ça ne m'embête pas et je réitère si
vous voulez et je réitère si vous voulez
vous prenez pas les décisions qui
peuvent déplire je réitère nous verrons
nous verrons maître Colard combien
d'Ur sera supportable dans ce pays et
Suppé dans ce pays il y a des questions
de fond et ça n'est pas si simple que ça
contrairement à ce que vous essayer de
faire quoi vous vous lisez dans le mar
de café vous savez tout vous savez ce
qu'il faut
faireloign de la question Gilbert qui
était de savoir si le Front national
était prêt aussi à tenir un langage de
vérité sur les réformes à
accomplir je viens de vous le dire je vi
de vous dire que ce qui caractérise pour
moi la femme d'état ou l'homme d'État
c'est que contra moi je m'en excuse à ce
que vous avez dit même si ça ne fait pas
plaisir du reste ça ça ça amène à la
question du du septéna non renouvelable
ça même si ça ne fait pas plaisir on
prend la décision dans l'intérêt du pays
c'est vrai vous avez raison il faut
réduire la dépense publique c'est un
fait indiscutable mais vous prenez le
contraire alors pour nous expliquer là
il faut y rentrer dans le détail oui
j'ai raison c'est bien le problème 124
milliards le je ne rentre jamais dans
les détails je voudrais quelque chose
personnelle si je peux parler à Philippe
daller euh philippe Dallier vient de
faire un discours sur le courage en
politique économique et je le salue
simplement tout à l'heure on a entendu
le discours de daliier Philippe à propos
du budgetê c'est le même et bien
simplement vous avez proposé chers
collègues tout un tas de dépenses et
puis j'ai pas tellement vu où étaient
les recettes bon mais ce qui veut dire
que chacun peut parfois être entraîné
par genre de Ch bien dans la logique du
PS il cherche les recettes
supplémentaires face aux dépenses nous
on prend d'abord les économies ce que je
crois c'est que en effet il faut
beaucoup de courage et vous savez
souvient de mades de ce qu'a dit parfois
justement rard moi je rappelle ber voie
des mesures difficiles de l'or prises
aussi par là François Hollande manuel
Vals pas pour
l'instant oui un homme d'État il est
capable de faire des réforme difficile
parce que c'est l'intérêt commun
regardez quand on a créé la CSG je me
souviens très bien moi je l'ai voté la
CSG tout le monde était contre
aujourd'hui bon vous voyez et donc je
suis pour le courage en politique
maintenant je ne suis pas pour la
démagogie parce que je vous dis monsieur
Collard quand on regarde mais si vous me
permettez encore deux phrases ah je suis
heureux de vous avoir
encotre votre votre système hein quand
on voit exactement ce que vous vous
proposer le retour du franc par exemple
le fait de quitter l'Europe le fait que
de ce fait il y aura énormément
d'entreprises qui naturellement se
trouveront dans une situation
catastrophique parce qu'on vit des
exportations on exporte vers l'Europe le
protectionnisme c'est le retour au passé
et non seulement au passé mais à
l'inefficacité totale vous présentez une
conception de l'économie et d'ailleurs
vous le savez très bien oui qui est
parfaitement
archaïque qu arriéré même vous pouvez
dire non parce que moi je n'enloie pas
les injures que vous affectionné moi je
vous dis simplement que quand on lit
votre programme économique on voit que
ce programme est une totale imposture il
faut
l'entendre savoir parce que ça fera le
plus grand tort au pays vous expliquez
que demain on quitte l'Europe qu'on
revient au franc qu'il y a une énorme
dévaluationors
jeis tout et c'est pour nous avons pris
des décisions don on Al
tout des décisions pour
éviterar que l'on arrive à cette
situation peine répondre devant tel
modèle politique je vais je vais modest
er d'abord un constat est-ce que dans
notre histoire la situation économique
aelle éta une fois plus grave non mais
pendant la guerre de 100
ans vous avez échoué surt surtout le
chômage est endémique oui la fiscalité
est affolante la société est fissurée
les pouvoirs publics sont impuissants et
on a un sentiment de décl ça c'est le
constat on l'a posé qu'est-ce que'est-ce
que vous
proposez Cagne électorale pour des GO
vous gogos vous prenez
gensz g pour des êes inintellig il sont
capables de
GO je crois je crois que ce que je
viensé
n je crois que ce que je viens d'évoquer
fait consensus bon et que très peu de
gens me dirai ce que vous venez de dire
n'est pas vrai le chômage n'est pas
endémique et CETA et ca et ca bon et
donc on revient à la retraite à 60
anslerèm l'une des propositions de
Mar comment on fait comment on fait pour
la financer on laisse finir
Gilber vousez d venir à 5 la me vous je
peux tout seul parler mais vous pouvez
et du reste je vous dire une chose ce
qui va être dramatique pour vous quand
on va voir l'émission ou à moins qu'elle
soit en direct je n'en sais rien c'est
que vous avez l'air tellement de bien
vous entendre tellement de bienend
fallait bien que ça se termine là vous
avez l'air alors en ce qui concerne
l'euro en ce qui concerne l'euro parceon
est capable de se parler sans s'injurier
et alors on a l' vous es une prétention
qui est insupportable voilà la
vérité allez vous avez
Gilber alors vous avez 30 secondes pour
conclure pour conclure c'est que nous
ferons un référendum sur la sortie de
l'E et qu'il est bien clair que c'est en
fonction de ce référendum que nous nous
déciderons ensuite la sortie de l' euro
sera pondéré maîtrisé et il y aura pas
de choc thermique parce que on le fera
en prenant le temps quand on voit ce que
l'Europe fait vous devriez avoir honte
de défendre cette Europe humilie les
peup c'est Philippe daller qui va
conclure parce qu'il a encore c'est
intéressant sur la sortie de l'euro
maintenant le discours c'est de dire on
demandera aux Français ce qu'ils en
pensent et puis on verra bien je croyais
que la responsabilité des politiques
c'était de leur dire voilà ce qu'il faut
faire voilà ce qu'il faut faire et voilà
pourquoi ça va régler les
problèm enc une encore une fois ce débat
l'aura démontré on peut pas rentrer dans
dans le détail des choses on ne peut pas
rentrer dans le détail des
chosesc la ben écoutez j'ai envie de
vous dire parce que franchement on voit
bien qu'à chacune de ces questions vous
esquivez mais qu'est-ce que vous
finissez vous finissez par refaire les
mêmes tours de pass-p et on revient au
début de l'émission RA votre programme
économique ne tient pas la route vous
seriez incapable de le financer tenu la
route nous avons aujourd'hui 2100
milliards d'euros de dett c'est un
constat vous nous proposez de dépenser
124 milliards c'est le chiffrage qu'on
en a fait vous êtes incapable de
financer ce que vous proposer et vous
nous feriez sortir de l'euro par-dessus
le marché avec les
dévaluations par
écoutend m'z l' de
pas rendez-vous pour un débat
économiquead de la campagne
présidentielle on pour faire merci à
tous les trois merci pour certains
d'avoir tenu plus difficilement alors
Monsieur moi je
vousci respect pour vous et pour
philippe Dallier pour les
téléspectateurs bonsoir à tous mer
bonsoir
[Musique]